the elderly man pretending to be
President Joseph R Biden he's releasing
our strategic petroleum Reserve now our
strategic petroleum Reserve has the word
Reserve in it and that means that it is
reserved for emergencies like if all
hell broke loose or there suddenly was
World War III or we had massive pipes
burst or a nuclear accident or a whole
series of crazy things happen then we
have our reserves so you don't want to
really be tapping into these things for
no reason uh but that's what we are
doing right now uh here is video of
televised mental institution MSNBC host
Chris Hayes saying why gas prices are so
high and you're not going to believe it
it has nothing to do with the Democrats
oil companies OPEC Saudi is not exactly
eager to make sure prices are low before
an election where Democratic candidates
are vulnerable
it's also why Saudi Arabia might want to
suddenly announce a cut in oil
production right before the midterms of
course Democrats can't just throw their
hands up and say oh well
because
the future of American democracy is in
as we report night and night out on this
program real Peril existential Peril
people have complicated and busy lives
and they've got things they're thinking
about when they go to the polls like the
cost of living inflation and yes gas
prices the one price in America that is
posted on every street corner those
digits they are going to be front of
mine for voters
and so we find ourselves in a situation
where keeping gas prices low
is key to preserving and strengthening
the future of our democracy and so here
we are that's Biden releasing oil from
the reserves day
and all this speaks to what the future
of our lectures look like alternative
Universe man if you're watching that
show you are in an alternative Universe
from the one that I exist in uh yes it
has nothing to do with the fact that
everyone from this Administration has
been talking about the green New Deal
and destroying fossil fuels ending
fossil fuels as Joe Biden has said on
more than one occasion it has nothing to
do with not unleashing American Energy
we've got plenty of oil of course we do
they don't want to go to it because they
want as gay Pete said they want you to
get an electric car you schmuck what are
you doing with your regular gas guzzler
what do you mean you can't afford a
seventy thousand dollar Tesla get moving
out there do you even work what are you
doing people
um it's of course complete nonsense that
all of our problems this is what they do
with everything all of our oil problems
and our gas problems and our energy
problems though that's on Saudi Arabia
and that's on OPEC right when we have
other problems related to all of the
this and energy who is it it wasn't that
it has anything to do with that that was
Russia and Putin's price like it is sure
I'm in charge I'm Joe Biden I'm supposed
to be the leader of the country but it's
nothing to do with what I'm doing come
on guys I'm eating ice cream I'm out
there doing everything I can chocolate
chocolate chip